Millennials they need to have meaning
when you grow up in a world of abundance
your basic needs are met okay so like
that's just an expectation of course I'm
gonna get a salary and of course I'm
gonna get benefits what I want is a job
that has meaning to me that connects to
my life purpose and you can only have
that if you have a really strong culture
that says here's who we are as an
organization here's what here's what it
matters here's why it matters to us to
be this way organizations that are clear
on that are gonna be more appealing the
Millennials than the organizations that
simply say we do XYZ work and we have
this opening position and you should you
should work for us and and that's it the
organizations we saw there doing this
are designing their organizations around
the needs of the employees and not the
needs of Management and they're making
it there it's work experience
customizable and they're building in
continuous innovation and improvement
into management which is new right we
used to sort of come up with our best
practice and as soon as we had that we
did that for the next 20 years that
doesn't work anymore we have to be more
fluid the traditional organization
relies heavily on hierarchy and heavily
on paying your dues all right so in
order to advance in the company the
standard rule is you have to come there
you have to work you have to dude you
have to do work you don't like for a
certain period of time so that you can
graduate to a different level where you
get to do work that's a little bit
better and then work them some more and
then eventually start managing people
and eventually start having authority to
make decisions or do things on your own
that organization just doesn't make
sense to Millennials I mean we
interviewed Millennials for this book
and the general theme from our response
from the Millennials was why are you
guys running it like this like would
they this they're literally scratching
their head saying why would you why
would you run an organization like this
why would you not empower people who are
closest to the customer for instance to
make a decision why would you why would
you not share information like that's a
huge women organizations that
Millennials don't get to some extent the
earlier generations are gonna have to
learn to give up control that's a that's
a big theme I'm
seeing in organizations that that you
know most of our management systems are
based on control being a good thing and
I'm finding organizations that give up
on that actually get to achieve more and
so I think the smart organizations are
gonna get clearer looking at their
millennial workforce much of much of
whom are gonna be entry-level to say I
know you're entry-level but in this area
I'm gonna let you run with it like
within these walls you can do whatever
you want you can experiment you can be
in charge and so you just have to be
clear about where those walls are so
that they don't have huge impacts on the
rest of the enterprise but find places
early on to do that so they have the
experience of making their own decisions
I also think in general organizations
will be pleasantly surprised when they
start letting their employees experiment
because I think they'll start seeing
results that they wouldn't have
predicted that they would get